the president Trump is making mental
health a focus of his efforts to curb
gun violence in meetings this week the
president said he aims to toughen
background checks with mental health
screenings and improve access to care
but while health experts welcomed more
resources and attention some say the
solutions are more complicated earlier
this week we heard from a panel of six
people directly affected by gun violence
Columbine shooting survivor Austin
Eubanks offered his thoughts on the
complex problem it's not just mental
health and it's not just weapons you
have to look at the presence of adverse
childhood experiences that have been
prevalent in all of these perpetrators
that have led to isolation and
loneliness later in life that therefore
creates this ideation about committing a
crime of this nature psychologists and
CBS News contributor Lisa d'amour joins
us at the table to discuss Lisa good
morning good morning we keep hearing
that just because if you suffer from a
mental illness most mentally ill people
are not violent people or dangerous you
have to go to in all of these cases
seems to be their mentally ill that's
right and you know overwhelmingly people
who are mentally ill are not dangerous
and the other thing that we know is that
in most cases of violence there are a
lot of factors not mental illness that
bring violence about so we worry that we
are stigmatizing the mentally ill
unfairly and that we are not paying
attention to factors beyond mental
illness that do contribute to violence
factors like factors like having a
history of violence having access to
weaponry those things that we know are
really significant we've heard a lot
about people saying you know if you see
anything any of these kinds of behavior
give us some sense though about the
extent to which I mean we all were
growing up there were kids who said
things that were out of bounds they
never did anything give us a sense of of
what it's like as an adolescent and what
we should be looking for sure so you
know our efforts to come up with some
perfect personality profile that will
you know tell us this person will commit
violence those don't work
what we do know always is that the best
predictor of future behavior is past
behavior so if somebody has been violent
if they are threatening if they're
saying they want to harm people we
should take that there
seriously something we heard from the
president yesterday was his belief that
there were a lack of mental institutions
in facilities to treat some of these
people in the country he cited New York
as an example are there a lack of mental
institutions in this country well we did
away with mental institutions for good
reasons
there is certainly a lack of adequate
services there are a lot of gaps in our
system and we need to fill those and
bring back you know services that really
can catch people in a social safety net
but you cannot ethically or practically
detain large numbers of people because
you think they might be violent so what
are the steps though I mean he mentioned
that that this this buckless Cruz didn't
have any criminal past there there were
sort of nowhere to put him nothing to do
with him what are the steps in a
situation like that but one thing that
we need we need excellent educational
facilities that can take care of kids
who are also having emotional and
behavioral problems you know and that is
part of a safety net that we actually
need to enhance you know there are
things like that I also think we have to
be realistic that there's no way to
perfectly predict or prevent violence
and so mental health solutions will
always be partial we're always going to
need other solutions to does this case
feel different to you this time as a
psychologist and a mother I'm wondering
as you're watching this people keep
thinking thinking maybe this time there
will be changes what are you looking at
what are you thinking well you know it's
been quite remarkable to watch these
teenagers in parkland to respond and
there is something that feels different
you know one is I think for many there's
been a sense of helplessness in the face
of these events especially as they
continue to occur in policies and laws
don't change and so these teenagers have
refused to be helpless and you know
these teenagers bring a couple of things
to the table that we haven't seen before
you know one is they are teenagers who
are willing to exercise their
willingness to question authority which
teenagers are very good at doing the
other thing is that they were they're
you know they are talking as witnesses
they are talking as survivors and that's
a pretty powerful combination and
they're also gonna be mentally scarred
as well Austin Eubanks who I spoke with
the Columbine survivor very lucky yes
guard for life he says he still he still
battles the trauma from surviving these
are traumas
and people who survive you know are
still heavily traumatized
Lisa two more thank you so much great
thank you once that